cpac the conservative political
action conference is this weekend it is
going to be
a uh an amalgam of a disgusting cast of
characters
culminating on sunday with a speech yes
from former president donald trump his
first
on-camera speech since leaving the white
house
more than a month ago and we are going
to be covering that live on sunday
but cpac is running into a little bit of
a problem
cpac uh it turns out invited a speaker
who goes by the name young pharaoh
and unfortunately young pharaoh has said
horribly anti-semitic things including
completely hare-brained wacky cuckoo for
cocoa puffs
conspiracy theories and pharaoh young
pharaoh
has now been pulled as a speaker the
daily beast reports
that young pharaoh once tweeted out
there is no historical
or scientific evidence proving the
existence
of jews or judaism it's all a complete
lie
made up for political gain he also
attacked fellow right-wing
uh commentator ben shapiro for
his judaism according to media matters
he also has conspiracies
about uh pizzagate the coronavirus
vaccine
and a whole bunch of other things as
reported
by eric hananoki he
a young pharaoh in the past year claimed
that judaism
in itself is a quote complete lie that
the jewish people
are thieving and that all of the
censorship
and pedophilia mind you on social media
is being done by israeli jews
specifically um he has now been pulled
now one of the funniest aspects of this
and it's funny in a way that's tragic
is that cpac put out a statement
saying quote we have just learned that
someone we invited to cpac has expressed
reprehensible views that have no
home with our conference or our
organization
the individual will not be participating
in our conference the funny thing about
that is
it essentially applies to everybody that
is speaking at cpac
up to and including donald trump i mean
look at look at the wording
someone we invited expressed
reprehensible views
that trump is at the absolute top of
that list
so if they were going to go by that
standard
um cpac would have to be canceled what
cpac actually means
is someone's reprehensible views went
beyond being considered reprehensible
only by the left and even some people on
the right consider these views
reprehensible
so at this point we really have no
choice but to cancel
the speaking engagement of young pharaoh
now speaking of cancellation
one of the new prominent memes
on the right around free speech and
suppression of speech is so-called
left-wing
cancel culture which includes of course
at the micro level
and i'm doing my best to represent the
the hypothesis
uh left-wing individuals employers and
organizations quote canceling people
when they have the quote wrong opinion
about things and it goes up to and is
inclusive of
twitter at large including its terms of
service
big picture youtube facebook basically
anyone who has ever limited the ability
of right-wingers to continue publishing
weaponized speech uh including that
which targets
all sorts of different individuals based
on membership in different protected
classes
that's cancel culture according to the
right but what's very funny
or maybe it's not funny maybe it's just
sad and ironic is that
uh when uh fox news canceled
lou dobbs because lou dobbs was giving a
ridiculously uh um uh not based in fact
opinion
about the election of uh joe biden in
november
fox news said he's got to go and they
canceled lou dobbs
and yet in the days following in all of
the segments about cancel culture on fox
news and newsmax and oan
they didn't mention lou dobbs being
cancelled now
the right-wing conservative political
action conference
has canceled a right-wing commentator
for his opinions that's not part of the
cancel culture
even though they won't stop talking
about bill de blasio this
and twitter that and susan wojcicki
wizki
uh that other thing based on what
youtube twitter or others are doing so
even the idea that they care about
cancel culture
is laughably untrue they care only about
instances of repercussions to speech
that are politically advantageous for
them that's all it is